man where we watch I got an idea they're
a Canadian film crew for a
science-fiction movie hey youtubers it's
Charlie and Ben Affleck is Batman that's
right Ben Affleck is replacing Christian
Bale as Batman on the franchise he'll
appear in the Superman vs Batman movie
first so I thought I'd talk a little bit
about what's going on and what that
means for the franchise
though Christopher Nolan and Christian
Bale are off the franchise completely
that's right they were kind of a package
deal
Christian Bale had already been very
clear about the fact that he didn't want
to be Batman anymore so they're already
looking for another actor but now that
Christopher Nolan is off the franchise
tooth they need another writer and
director obviously Christopher Nolan had
a lot of help writing that script so Ben
Affleck probably won't be the only
person to end up writing whatever this
next Batman movie ends up being but it's
totally possible that he will be the
writer and director in addition if this
Superman vs Batman movie team-up goes
well it's totally possible that we could
see Ben Affleck directing the Justice
League movie to the most of you've been
talking about Ben Affleck as Batman in
the comments and you're pretty divided
so a lot of people really hate the idea
and a lot of people are really excited
about the idea but honestly I think we
need to think more about Ben Affleck as
a writer director on this franchise as
opposed to him playing the role let's
talk a little bit about how he came to
be Batman and how this ended up
happening right now Ben Affleck is so
embedded in the culture of Warner
Brothers that I honestly think that he
was the first person at the top of their
list obviously for a role as big as
Batman
you probably auditioned everyone in
Hollywood that's capable of doing it but
there's very few people who can write
act and direct a movie so honestly I
think they're looking at the set Affleck
is the creative director of the Batman
franchise going forward obviously the
Superman versus Batman movie is just a
dry run because whatever his role is in
the movie it'll be minimal it's
basically Henry Cavill sequel so it's a
Superman movie with Batman in it one of
the really important things that Affleck
brings to the table that a lot of other
directors don't is award show
credibility so last year at the Oscars
Argo was killing it so obviously we know
that Affleck can write and direct and
he's been nominated for Oscars in both
categories but he's also an
oscar-nominated actor too and there are
very few actors in Hollywood who have
all those three bases covered I honestly
think that Warner Brothers is taking
this really seriously going forward
Christopher Nolan was almost shut out of
most of the Oscar categories and most
super
films really only get nominated in
technical categories so I think they're
really looking for an oscar-winning
director to write an amazing script I
even think the Affleck is going to get a
pass at that Superman versus Batman
movie script to Zack Snyder actually
writes a lot of his own scripts but he
got a lot of help from David Esquire on
the Man of Steel movie and there were a
lot of criticisms and they did have
pushed it for Nolan as an advisor but
Christopher Nolan will not be helping
out with the second Man of Steel movie
he'll be consultant only so he won't be
working on the script so I honestly
think that Affleck is going to kind of
step in and fill that role he obviously
won't be the lead writer but I think
that he wouldn't sign on to a movie this
big without getting a pass at that
script but let's talk about the timing
of the announcement don't you feel like
it was a little bit rushed I really
think the reason for this is just that
Warner Brothers really wanted to make an
official statement on their own schedule
if you remember yesterday I did a
Bradley Cooper video for guardians of
the galaxy and that announcement was
actually leaked I think that Warner
Brothers saw that and they said hey we
need to get this news out there as fast
as possible and we are heading into
awards season so I think that they want
to associate Batman with Oscars but let
me know what you think about the idea of
Ben Affleck as Batman
and what you think about the idea of him
writing a Batman movie or even directing
it I think it's gonna be really hard for
Ben Affleck to direct a movie that he's
acting in that's over 150 million
dollars but if anybody can do it I think
he can do it I mean he's really used to
smaller films but let me know what you
think and let's talk a little bit about
the look of this new Batman it's gonna
be a long time before we see any photos
from the set of the Superman versus
Batman movie but I'm really interested
to see what the visual style of this new
Batman movie is and if that is going to
change from the Superman vs Batman movie
to the new standalone Batman movie I
honestly I think because now that
they've announced Affleck that they're
going to release the next Batman movie
before Justice League comes to and if
that goes well then we'll definitely see
Ben Affleck kind of leading the Justice
League team just because he kind of
brings that award show credibility that
Zack Snyder doesn't have I think
whatever they end up doing it's not
going to be able to top Christopher
Nolan's vision of Batman so I think
they're probably going to try and do
something a little bit different with
the franchise let me know what you think
that is honestly I think the Ben Affleck
does characters really well so I think
it's going to be much more
character-driven film whatever it ends
up being but we probably won't find out
for several years a lot of my friends
and a lot of other people have been
talking
about the Kevin Smith Batman idea
because remember Affleck kind of got a
start in the comic book world through
the blunt man and cronic stuff so
wouldn't it be hilarious to see kevin
smith directed Batman film with Affleck
and Matt Damon they'd just be so
hilarious it would totally never happen
but it would be amazing to see anyway
final thoughts on Ben Affleck as Batman
pics or it didn't happen I have to see
some pictures of him doing costume tests
doing acting tests I really want to see
what this is going to look like in this
Superman vs Batman movie before I pass
official judgement but I'm tentatively
very optimistic and I think it's gonna
be really exciting
be sure to HiFi them for winning the
role I'm sure every other actor in
Hollywood auditioned for this so I'll be
doing tons more Superman vs Batman
videos as well as ben affleck batman
videos this fall be sure to subscribe to
get them all and if you really want to
help me out be sure to like and share
this video if you haven't seen my
bradley cooper guardians of the galaxy
video you can click here to watch that
and you can click here to watch my Peter
Jackson Doctor Who series 8 video thanks
so much for watching
high five to Ben Affleck Congrats man
see you guys tomorrow
you